president biden is set to unleash
disastrous liberal crime reform policies
nationwide despite a rise in violence
across the country the administration's
proposing eliminating cash bail to
promote gender equity
yeah you heard that right the ridiculous
42-page report calling for a whole of
government approach quote
we will work to end cash bail and reform
our pre-trial system recognizing the
harm these processes cause particularly
for black women and families
but we've seen example after example of
the awful consequences of this policy in
liberal cities you may remember this
woman accused of shoving another person
into an approaching new york city subway
train
she was freed without bail in july for a
different vicious assault
and how about this guy he made the cover
of the new york post after being
arrested ready 57 times
this year alone
greg i don't get it you empty the
prisons in the middle of a crime wave
tell me why this makes sense well it
does make sense because if you're
eliminating cash bail to promote gender
equity you're ending up with more women
who are crime victims we've noticed this
in new york city the bulk of the women
that are being attacked on the streets
are women women who have died women in
times square women in canal street uh
subway station pushdown died so
basically they've decided that if we can
create more female murder victims that's
equity too they're redistributing
they're redistributing the murder
congrats on on finally finding equality
in the suffering of other people i i
mean but it it raises the question we
are all
we all see the consequences the left
sees it the rights is it we see it so
why do you continue doing the same thing
when you know this is happening
you've accepted the death because the
governing ideology is one of oppression
oppression theology this country and its
current state is essentially a giant
slave holder and it needs to be taken
down so that means the byproducts of
these people dying they're just merely
you know byproducts it doesn't matter
that they're dead because the greater
thing is to overhaul society and and you
know that nobody they know that nobody
wants this they know that it's evil
which is why they're always burying it
in places like i don't think any of us
knew about the no cash bail until it
happened right we didn't like i wasn't
like we said it locally yeah but we
didn't yet but we didn't like it wasn't
there so they had they have to slip it
in and then if you when you bring it up
a left-wing d.a will call you racist
which is what happened when we brought
it up so now people are dying and
they're continuing it to do this it's
telling you they want this to happen
greg mentioned the ideology this began
on they i would call it the
revolutionary left martha the the
american intellectual left that they
thought that the prison system needed to
be abolished they needed to decarcerate
the population because
prisons were a tool of
white capitalists and the bible
administration moderate joe biden is
actually ascribing to this crazy
ideology yeah a couple of things one
thing is that you know i don't think you
have to worry about bail because most
people aren't going to jail anyway um
you've got people shooting up in the
street they don't go to jail you can
steal a car and drive away you're
probably not going to go to jail um
there's a lot of offenses that you don't
even ever get to that point so they've
already established uh that level of
freedom for people on the other hand you
know when you go back to the election
jesse um and you you look at the what
both kamala harris and joe biden had to
fight off was that they had the sort of
stink on them of the 1994 crime bill
right so they had been tough on crime
and this is what happens with
politicians because they're like oh yeah
remember that wave when we had to tell
everybody we were going to be really
tough on crime because that was what was
working um and then all of a sudden it
wasn't working anymore but i looked back
at some of what joe biden said back then
and he said this is like he actually not
even back then this was in 2016. joe
biden said that the crime bill restored
american cities
so raise your hand if you don't want to
restore american cities look at what has
happened to the great cities of this
country i don't think you know i think
it's a tiny tiny margin of people that
say i'd rather have cash bail or i'd
rather have american cities restored so
i think you're going to have to have a
pendulum swing if 2022
what year's gonna be 2022. that goes um
the wrong way for democrats i think
you're going to start seeing a bill
clinton revival of like welfare to work
and tough on crime and all these things
are going to figure out oh you know what
it doesn't work so we better go back the
other way bill clinton revival greg
can be interesting on a number of levels
so geraldo
we mentioned they've been studies about
this in chicago new york city about cash
bail about cash bail people get out they
reoffend or they just don't show up to
trial right well let me make the token
progressive argument against cash bail
you have to you have two you have two
defendants they commit the same exact
crime one has some wealth the other is
broke uh the bale's a thousand dollars
five thousand dollars whatever it is a
hundred thousand dollars the rich
criminal can put up bail the poor
criminal is stuck in jail incarcerated
until not even until
proven guilty but not even tried but
someone called that equality yeah that
is right it is not equity the equality
right well i think uh you know
even treat they say that the
only the the poor and the rich can
ban from sleeping under the bridges uh
you know but only the poor obviously
sleep under the bridges uh but i hate as
much i hate to agree with you
it is not it is not appropriate given
the epidemic of violent crime that we're
now facing it's not about a theoretical
equity right it's about safety it's
about you know mom pond the you know
your wife and your children uh walking
down the street and having uh
you know getting heisted jacked
assaulted
uh homicide now the number one cause of
death among young black men under the
age of 44. it's a it's horrifying what
is happening and for a liberal to stick
to a progressive technical point when in
the in the face of this harsh reality is
why liberalism per se is under attack
because it's so illogical in many ways
and they're not focusing on crime
victims katie yeah right well maybe the
left should be more focused on trying to
implement programs that would allow
black men to live past the age of 34
instead of shooting each other so
instead of coming up with some kind of
program for the inner cities that they
could implement through the justice
department they are focused on this
equity that they're pushing off that
really doesn't mean anything it's just a
lot of gobbly [ __ ] for the left and also
it tears down the system that they think
can't be reformed democrats are picking
a side here they know what cash bail
does that no cash bill does they've seen
it happen they can see the crime
statistics and yet they are choosing to
continue to do this and they want to
implement it on a national scale they
are taking the side of the criminals and
when you are allowing a left that
doesn't believe in a system that we have
of due process instead we are going to
do justice based on your skin color this
is the result of that unfortunately for
them the results are that minorities are
the ones who are impacted the most and
when you go into these communities and
actually ask people who live there
rather than the aoc's who live in
high-rise buildings above the whole
foods they will tell you we want more
police not less policing we want people
to be in jail we're sick of seeing these
criminals on the street running our
neighborhoods when we have no say
whatsoever and so this is just another
distraction and it's not just you know
that there are consequences for it for
people who actually live in these
neighborhoods who don't want their
two-year-olds to get shot when they go
to a barbecue for fourth of july
i i don't know how bills work i'll be
honest with you but if if you're a
democrat and you're for no cash bail
there has to be a way to introduce a
bill that that removes private security
from your
world that if you're for no cash bail
you don't get any private security so
you're just as vulnerable as everybody
else i'll talk to some of my buddies in
congress we'll work something like that
thank you i knew you knew somebody all
right i know a few people i recommend
schoolhouse rock too it explains how
bills work
you literally are in the news business
maybe you should know a little bit craig
no i disagree hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else